the Academy award-winning director of
Apollo 13 brings us his next epic and
the dilemma is the story of two best
friends played by comedies favorite fat
dudes Kevin James and Vince Vaughn then
Vince Vaughn catches Kevin James's wife
played by Winona Ryder making out with
Channing Tatum in a garden and well now
we have the dilemma I mean Kevin James
is pretty stressed from work so does he
tell and burden him does he not tell
does he wait now first the movie starts
out it looks like it's gonna be pretty
solid I mean I like the characters
Jennifer Connelly's awesome Vince Vaughn
and Kevin James were funny they worked
well together Winona Ryder was in it so
I thought okay this movie's gonna poke
fun at relationships and cheating I
thought I could appreciate that but the
movie it just doesn't know where wants
to go after that well I don't know where
I would find this movie in like
blockbuster what category or this is
2011 so Netflix is it a drama with some
comedy in it is it a comedy with some
drama in it I don't know because the
movie doesn't know it's like two
different movies the first half romantic
comedy the last third drama it lays it
on thick - man I'm not gonna lie it's
saturating it's like Boy Meets World in
the beginning comedy by the end absolute
soap opera I like Boy Meets World I'm
just saying that is what happened I mean
some drama is fine in a comedy in fact
it's necessary but it's kind of like
ketchup and fries ever just slather the
ketchup on your fries then when you're
eating and you're like I might as well
not even have fries I can't taste the
fries all I taste is ketchup by the end
of this movie all you taste is the drama
I mean look at that poster does that
scream drama look at that grin that is
not a dramatic grin as Kevin James
comedic King of Queens surprisingly the
character that stands out that I really
liked I shouldn't be saying I should
never say this sentence ever Channing
Tatum's character his character just
stands out it was actually pretty funny
again I should never ever say that ever
and I recognized that but here we are
I mean his character stands out and he
was memorable I did not taste ketchup
not with that dude let's rephrase that
and the end it started out pretty funny
being disjointed and had some funny
parts but the drama just overshadowed
everything - like an unenjoyable degree
so it knocked it down a peg or two -
it's okay but you're not gonna remember
it in t minus 13 hours there you go but
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more then click right
here to see more